in welcoming into the Wednesday
afternoon Android developer relations
office hours hangout I'm Sparky coming
to you from Munich Germany and I'm also
joined by my teammates rich and Nick and
Peter in London UK so with that let's
kick off the hang out and see what
people are talking about in the field of
Android development there's nobody in
the Hangout yet so let's go to the
moderator and see what we've got cued up
I've got my moderator right here a
little bit of a slow week in the
moderator got three questions right
before the hang outside and it had to
look into those but Mitchell from
Denmark sighs I would love to get a
guide to set up the emulator with
android 4.2 and an extra large screen
with 1920 x 1200 resolution oh my
goodness ok I've tried all the
combinations and they all crash with a
bunch of OpenGL errors hmm out of memory
perhaps with new devices coming this is
essential he says further he's trying
api level 15 army a BF e'l'ith Davi and
v7a no snapshot cetera et cetera my
first thought in response to that is
testing 1920 x 1200 in an emulator is a
recipe for pain so I hope Mitchell is
tough and my other thought is maybe try
playing with the google TV sdk which at
least comes out of the box ready for
1080p this is a good idea Sparkie I
hadn't thought about the google TV sdk
what are they saying are the reasons for
failing when you use a normal emulator
he doesn't say and and I haven't I
haven't looked into it so any other is
Italy they had a beta release right now
so it's not guaranteed to work with all
hardware configurations and so on but
they are looking for
robots so take these stack traces and if
you go to source or android com you'll
find a link to the where you can find a
bug with this information all right just
don't have enough power I want to try it
myself and see if I can set up one with
that screen resolution especially using
the hardware acceleration I've been
really enjoying using the hardware
accelerated emulator and making videos
from it and things like that so possibly
with that I could push out a 1920 but
I'll test it as Latin there any devices
to that resolution yet anyone nasal yeah
toshiba meant one that one of the
conference's so they have one bear and
had the resolution of it I don't
somebody had a 13 inch tablet but it was
filling it 100 pixel yeah that's all
I've seen is worth 13 inches of Android
glory my death hmm Oh alive though
unfortunately much as I would love to if
you were joined in the hell now by our
first victim I mean developer a heytell
I was gonna tella be alright it's going
pretty well you know loads of sunshine a
lot of Sun it's really hot also but
still fun so so what are you do to
escape the heat do do you go to the
beach review retreat into an
air-conditioned building encoded when
their conditioning invention is one of
the most amazing inventions on there
yeah well i lived in houston texas for
five years and i would i would tuck in
you on that one I don't know how people
lived here before their conditional or
in the summer especially in the
southeast which is like 40 Celsius I
don't think they did I think they I
think they all lived up in Greenland as
the climate you know as a climate heated
up they were treated for their weighing
as a cool name for their salt and I
don't think there is any human presence
in the middle east before about 1955
so I steeper joining the Hangout by
Michael Handler and Paul blundell so
welcome guys do you have any any
questions about android development
you'd like to ask us crickets michael
says in the chatter he's purchased
something in Nevada razor LC will matter
eater yeah Mike eight she's like okay I
know in the documentation it says that
calling this method will not ensure that
files deleted but I tried calling delete
on exit and nothing seems to delete the
fine at all any of this is that it would
cause afar to be deleted yes reboot I
looked up the documentation on that one
and it says what what's exiting when
those files are deleted is the virtual
machine itself which is basically up as
long as your android device is running
so it requires a shutdown of Android for
those files to get deleted excellent see
okay that was that question Wow zooming
through a prepared content haha well we
could always talk about subscriptions
when I'm just checking the stream and it
looks like we don't have any other
comments right now I just like to see a
movie oh ok yeah so just next one from
the moderator or we come from the
moderator this works Bucky well let's
see yeah we got we got three that a
triple question that came in all the
last minute ok but before I get to that
let's let's take this one from chinmoy
in chennai india who says i'm a teenager
and i'm looking for tips getting started
developing an android we can anyone to
help well yeah there's lots of places to
go for help I would start by just doing
a Google search or go to
developer.android.com and start reading
the introductory articles or do that
little android a coma such pain yeah
there you go
right if if you want there's a slightly
more collective list of places to start
I put it all together into a blog post
and you can see it in my personal blog
which believe it or not is tell it to
the blog com so if you go there you can
see sort of a little summary of our
advice for places to start looking for
introductory Android development
materials good tip but for me the thing
to do is open up some example code and
start messing around with it that's how
i got into android the day on my first
android device I found lead project
hello world get on the device and as
soon as you have your first step running
on the device which is quite easy you
just plug it in and it should appear in
the Android debug bridge ah yeah you
just get up straight away and then being
able to have your act in your pockets
just awesome so I think your passion
will drive you to learn android at that
point stack overflow and whatever means
possible when I use them to start
Android we have this amazing isn't any
website that really as a good tutorial
now to start the web for Android that is
actually enabled so maybe to search also
for a local language tutorial you know
whoa so the question coming in the chat
window from Nam he says he's out of
memory I'm sorry what did he say haha
out of memory on what I'll called memory
movement that out of out of heap space
are you dealing with large images you
need to maybe rescale your images before
you decode them yes it's bitmaps okay
okay there's an Android training
protocol for that if there is an Android
training school for that large images
are ruining my life says mine too what
rich is this going around for the
correct training course we've just
launched a training ice-cold teaching
exactly how to deal with this problem
but some ways
basically load as little as possible so
don't load a full-size image and then
scale it down for you I just go get the
size you want yes but i'm building a
launcher okay i'll look for both okay
and you might have steal a large images
but you're never going to show them at
their full resolution i take it here we
go I've got the link our Sparky beat me
to it makes a great watching everyone
play on the livestream watching us reach
excellent display my best we also had
one on the developers blog right
probably yeah there was there was
there's an article a couple years back
that talked about things like you're
calling bitmap recycle and things like
that our goal anyway i can make sure the
garbage collector rhesus memory yeah Cal
recycle on your bitmaps cool bitmap
don't recycle don't go system that GC
yeah we with deprecated system GC
starting I think with was a gingerbread
or was at Royal when we when we improve
our exposure yeah Jin's we've had the
update a club that's here okay it's not
that it's not reliable is that it's just
not necessary oh looks like the Android
training classes the most definitive
guide at the moment system GC isn't
reliable right oh fun reliable it
doesn't necessarily don't know just is
that it would be good to do it soon most
of the time you wouldn't want to call
system GC unless you've recycled a lot
of bitmaps reset any right now it's sort
of a high level or
yeah you need two more final finite
control if this process the time system
da GC is going to run anyway it's going
to garbage collector say anyway but if
you are if you have just cleaned up a
whole lot of memory you can call system
GC to prompt the system that now would
be a good time to do it so it may run
sooner than it was going to but
certainly you don't want kind of a loop
running it one you don't want to run it
unnecessarily it should manage itself
here staring its side of the screen
again if there's my eyes the chat window
or we need from able to actually kick
the next moderator question today we've
got a 1c oh geez I don't ruin request
these how to prevent all right Steve but
how to prevent the background from being
distorted when the window is resized I
presume that made something like an
orientation change or something the
background is patterned so it's visible
I'd rather be cropped well there are
made are attributes that you can set in
your XML but to find how things are
cropped stretch or centered and I think
you just look at the reference and
specify the right one of those that's
I'll make you guys Todd's fit they don't
remember the exact syntax of it but it's
something that you can put in your like
image online in your alliance attribute
or something like that let's see auto
hide keyboard how do we auto hide the
keyboard that's another one of our
questions from the moderator let's do
you have to would you have to override
on touch in your view anywhere or is
there another way to do it like say I
know on field loses focus or something
like that maybe you guys with a little
more you I experience Canada what's the
event that you trying to hurt people I
you the question was how can I auto hide
the keyboard
the user touches outside of the edit
text I guess you know something like
we're no longer editing this text so
make the Edit affordance go away yeah if
it doesn't happen automatically you can
have an old focus changed listener and
when the unfocused changed if the edit
text goes to not focus anymore you can
hide the keyboard there is a line of
code for hiding your keyboard again or
change the keyboard state to hidden is
that I Michael what's wrong with that if
there is anything wrong with it Michael
Michaels typing to the benefits of those
on the live stream now he didn't catch
that okay you can have an unfocused
change listener on the edit text wow so
I just come
hmm are you liking guys i don't i'm not
seeing your video I think London just
died blew up Thanks android a nice haha
right okay well I guess it's just us
then I'm sure they'll be back I hope
they'll be back they almost hang out
well I had a question if I know how I
see you yeah we're coming back in there
alright didn't want to Michael's
question for a second time we just drop
out instead all maybe well done no yes
sir michael i was going to say yet the
unfocused change the snow and then as
soon as the folks of the edit text
changes you can just like the keyboard
if you can't find the line of code
required by hiding the keyboard i can
dig it back out for you I've used it a
few times before we send the end of
manager a yeah you can manage or
something so the tower you can ask a
question s yes I wanted to ask him about
languages and keyboards and stuff like
that I got my hands on amazing galaxy s3
and apparently it has evil keyboard and
interface but for some reason samsung
chose to hide it away from you so you
cannot pick it but it's there because i
use Moloch l2 and it's still but it's
just not visible you cannot pick it but
if you use more local to its still now
the question is one why do you think
would they do that if you have an idea
and you samsung yeah because you know it
it's really annoying because just to
give you an idea of the money for like
you know in germany the galaxy s3 coast
like 580 us give or take and initially
it almost reaches its more than 900
viewers ah so you see it's really
annoying because the hippo is there they
just don't show it as a result you pay
for that little yours just to enjoy the
simple installed on your device to bring
about some some
that might actually be a plausible
reason because if if i recall correctly
you told me that you acquired this
device from outside of Israel yes it's a
non Hebrew of sku so I can see how maybe
they're they're trying to you know
trying to get some product
differentiation across their line
basically a fabulous for that the deal
is is a way to match for the employee
experience if you see what I mean yeah
well we don't we don't have any control
over how Samsung workers there goes that
if you need but you'll probably have no
connections to them than I have so if
you can pass it along to Samsung in some
kind of way then that would be great
because they really overcharge just too
after he will play installed on your
device it's another yeah unfortunately
we generally don't do those kind of
things we have people who work with
partners and they generally discuss
these kind of issues well can you give
me some women to contact them then i'll
send them even myself because really
it's a daily annoying because you know I
got lucky myself to get the cheaper the
galaxy s3 because by chance somebody was
in Germany but it's really annoying you
to see for somebody that is not a big
yeah Jerry concept enter something you
like or something like that you have to
agree samsung slide to find any contact
Esther that's not really an Android
development questions I when the
developer question Cearley would be can
I somehow put today make it visible and
use the keyboard and you know let the
keyboard be visible as part of the take
green start using enough using enough to
make you know because it's there it's
just not accessible not only way I
wouldn't know okay thank you dusty yes
sir I can't help you display that one ah
why shouldn't I make in-app billing
request from another thread because it's
done it and it's working
look is it possibly because you know
building does its own threading maybe
because it's got its own client library
yeah I'm not trouble work on all devices
no I've seen something about this before
but the edge will end up any requests
have to be made from the main threat of
the app especially pullin up pending
intent to launch them the Google Play
window which is why I mean it does need
to show some UI yeah I've known some
time to launch the pending intent which
you get returned from the main thread
but i'm not sure why you actually have
to do as you see unmade bed my best
guess would be that yeah it is actually
do its own thread inked is invoking my
pc but i have actually looked into a few
days I've had to check I hope that I
love that there's a little sidebar
conversation going on the chat window
from people who aren't actually talking
everyday believe what I write today we
are almost to the end of it really the
only question I've got left is the third
in the set when using windows soft input
mode equals adjust can can you specify a
second view which needs to be visible as
well such as a go button below the edit
text I have no idea why it as I said
this this question came in at the last
minute and I yeah I have no nothing
awful this one yeah that was actually my
question there is the I had three
questions about the virtual keyboard and
if you need to see an example of what I
mean I've got a question on Stack
Overflow I've just put the link on the
chat bar okay so here's a screenshot so
what I'm trying to do is one user taps
on that box that says sample the
keyboard comes up and pushes up the
whole view rather than only pushing up
the edit text if the edit text is
obscured
so as in I want make sure that bison
stays visible at the bottom so simple a
smile even with the Go button to the
right edit text well yeah I mean there's
ways of getting around about redesigning
the whole layout but what I'm going to
say wondering is if there's a way to
kind of not have to redesign the layout
because it's not actually mine it's
something the client wants me to do okay
yeah I'm not pay pretty much a week so
is it in just a linear layout I mean it
it's the go button anchored to the
fondant yeah it's a relative layout with
the but the go button anchor to the
bottom of the screen and then the this
is a simplification in the real layout
but basically the buttons anchor to the
bottom these sample boxes in the middle
and then there's a graphic at the top
that can get pushed out the screen if we
need to sure take the button off the
bottom of the screen and put it up in
the action bar ok so I'm hearing there's
no there's no real way to do this
because I'm guessing there's no way I
just haven't thought about it ok because
I know the other ways I can completely
redesign the layout and use a scrollview
and then have it just resize the scroll
of you and that will work but then it's
you can't use kind of a line parent both
phones with scroll views because there's
no defined height of the view so I just
have to redesign it well while we're
thinking about keyboard stuff the other
few questions about keyboards they were
also for me I was just I couldn't take
part earlier because I was trying to
figure out how to get the Hangout
working but I'm the one about making the
keyboard auto hide when you tap outside
of the edit text you said to use a on
focus change listener the problem is the
edit text doesn't actually get a focus
changed false if you tap in an area that
doesn't take focus itself oh ok I've
just posted a comment on that from Stack
Overflow there's a question there which
might answer if you look at the comments
for the hangout at the bottom Oh Carson
hang out right My Damn
out to comment the hang out here native
I in there in the Google bloodstream
yeah I don't see it on this kind of chat
bar on the side or on this the S on the
stack overflow is the chapel yeah yeah I
see it oh there we go oh no that's
that's that's very simple this is just
um hi hiding the keyboard when the user
taps a bus in your that I know how to do
okay promise you texting when the texas
focus yes oh this one is if they tap
anywhere on the screen it's not the edit
text I want the the keyboard to go away
now I found a way of doing this sorry
you put a listener on the viewer that
you can dinner uh yeah I suppose if we
do that that if we make the entire view
container focusable like that and I
guess that would work that's probably
easier than what I was starting to work
on which was your way around sorry what
was your weapon my workaround was using
a the dispatched overriding dispatched
touch event and then check checking the
location of the touch event whether it
was inside all over any edit texts on
the screen and if it wasn't then hiding
it but it's just more of a pain to do
that because I've got a dozen different
kind of forms that were to have edit
text so having to work on override that
on every on every fragment and was just
annoying I sounds a little bougie yeah
it seemed like there had to be a better
way to do it huh
yeah I don't know what happened I don't
have a lot of experience with this
particular part of the API it's a edit
text right yeah so maybe to do I don't
know where a class that inherits edit
text and then put it there somewhere and
then use that all over another
application or perhaps a sample just by
not playing around that is doing more or
less what you're trying to do but maybe
it's worthwhile just looking at the
source code of something well also I say
do you definitely want to do that I mean
yeah it's not the standard behavior
right there's no other like stock apps
which which do this behavior nothing
else have dismisses the keyboard when
you tap elsewhere right yeah that is
true there is them it's not standard
behavior but it's it's one of these
where they want an iphone version an
android version and they want them both
to behave the same way and no it's I've
told them that you can use the back
button to hide the keyboard but they
feel it's not intuitive enough so I
might push back at them and say this
isn't how Android works and say you know
you could pass implement a solution but
it's you know working it gets a platform
as it where you have to do kind of work
around so you don't want to do and try
and encourage them to a doctor android
behavior really i might do you know that
a case rotten you know writing some code
you don't want to write and maintain
there is war another thing you can do
you can listen to the touch events in
the other windows and as soon as you get
one hyper keyboard and if and then just
let the touch event handler continue to
process what was going to happen yeah
you can just do no action of the night
the keyboard and then just return it
yeah that's what the the workaround I
had at the moment is it's just it on
dispatch touch event it calls the checks
at where it fits and then the next line
is returns super on dispatch touch event
I mean the text box still does have the
focus it should still be up so are you
all so movingly blinking cursor out of
the text box as well you moving focus to
something else whereas the text box
still got focus just with no keyboard
I'm not doing anything with the blinking
cursor I'm not sure at least I
vegetables after you've clicked away the
keyboard this is new I mean them to show
actually what happens the dodo to let me
just check quickly I think it London
just left us again mas I succeeded in
the he'll join the group chat welcome
Android developers would you like to
talk about with development oh no that's
a good point actually I'm that uh if you
what I've got at the moment the blinking
cursor still stays on the edit text so
then how do you bring the keyboard back
up again you know that listening to some
all the time yeah yeah just anything
then if there's a touch event inside
another text it pops the keyboard back
up yeah let's see i'll just write back
and just say this is no a drug works
people won't expect the keyboard to
disappear when you touch away none of
the default app to do that including
gmail and you know all the search boxes
everything else don't behave in that
manner and it's strange I mean you have
an atlas feature parity on both
platforms but takes advantage of the UI
Patton Street battle I'm hoping that
you're not following iOS design
guidelines for the application well no I
am trying I'm trying to every battle
there there's a lot of battles with
decline about how to redesign the app
then I am trying to push back whoever
possible but I don't always win because
well they're the one pain all right they
all the work pain but if they want the
one he actually featured which I'm is
shooting the answer is yes follow the
Android design / yes that is a good
point a good way we couldn't you know
could I could I could fight with that we
have very few carrots and sticks yeah
we'll let pretty much any app into the
store unless bound to take sit down but
a big neighbor's dog fish it's the sort
of Google Play um but yeah you really
need to follow the design guidelines if
you ever want to send a chance of
getting featured or promoted or being
part of any of the even like the indie
game developer promotion that's going on
at the moment all these different things
the editorial team is very very hot on
that and older design guidelines
we understand it's quite hard sometimes
fighting back these n my client
requirements but you had things like
potentially be promoted is language they
sometimes understand also you can put
them at this point in the video but this
will be on YouTube live for the end of
time and then just play it back them
okay now I do think that it's very
admirable to want to have the same user
experience across all different versions
of your application but you can take it
too far as feminist art Wheeler says
here in the sidebar no do people really
have one of each device most people
probably don't and and you know they
would rather have the one that provides
similar functionality within the user
interface language that they know one
expect rather than one that is identical
to a platform they don't even have most
of the time so usually when you choose a
platform usually don't change so often
once you look on this stuff you like you
don't you don't change you know not a
lot of people go for android to iphone
iphone to android usually stick with
what you start with a great way they do
change over they expect it to be
different they'd be quite surprised if
you weren't for one theater and
everything was the same it wouldn't
maybe worth switching i'll also
requiring all versions of your
application to adopt the exact same user
interface invention of one particular
version that you've selected is not
having a user interface division that is
outsourcing your design aesthetic to
another company Yeah right on until
different comment uh this when you
choose everything else and see what
we've got going on yeah can I ask
something about the camera because
that's something that I stuck it and
they looked for it and it since there is
no solution since 2008 so maybe you can
help me move that the home about the
camera when you use an intent to capture
a picture in sound devices when you put
it in portrait mode and then take a
picture it changes the picture with 90
degrees
say that again please yeah some devices
rotate the pixels and some just put it
in the exit and it's it's it's on the
galaxy s3 on the galaxy s2 but not on
the Galaxy Nexus for example the Galaxy
Nexus takes the picture returns its
correctly and the Garcias turn the
galaxy s3 only in polite Inlet escape it
it they all do it collect they change it
to 90 degrees and this is only happens
in portrait mode right another thing
that happens differently across some
devices is when you take a photo with
the building application and return it
back via intent you know say you provide
a storage location for it in the intent
extras you give a path some devices will
take that image and stash it in the
gallery some don't some will put it in
SD card /d sim which is the universal
standard location for photos and 10
won't because you gave it another
location unfortunately I say this is a
fun because you know intensive possible
to walk it the same way if you see I
cause say the platform right we we
define what has to be sent back to the
color through the intent on however our
platform does not actually dictate what
other side effects may or may not happen
with regard to that image so I it it's
true that they're not all consistent but
because we didn't say what they have to
do we can't really say they're wrong
either well then what's it suggested oh
yeah i mean i think that the right way
is to is to return the pixel array in
the natural orientation of the camera
sensor and use the exif data to indicate
what the orientation ought to be but
that's I mean that's my opinion that
given that the camera can figure out
which way it's pointed some people might
reasonably argue that it would be
correct to actually
the pixels so when the interesting thing
is when you take it in photo mode on the
galaxy s2 and galaxy s3 it shows you
when it turns it to 90 degrees it shows
you like it's at zero degrees it's not
online T so don't you cannot recognize
by the degree that it's in and then
change it back oh so one thing I thought
is instead of it'll just automatically
turn at 19 then instead of being screwed
by the galaxy s2 and galaxy s3 being
screwed by the Galaxy Nexus because
there's a lot less of them you should
write write a compatibility test suite
test the other thing you know the other
thing you can do is if you find that
that generally it sounds like you're
having problems or issues with Samsung
devices is sign up to date until I
developers blog and ask them if you find
that some api's aren't performing is not
really we specified sorry it's also HTC
and Sonic okay sure so in same thing
yeah that's why I see yes tax would be
perfect yeah I agree okay so this is why
this is why people who make platforms
like hate to have people actually use
them because they keep on running into
these implementation details just get
distracting everything is so much too
pure if you just read the online
documentation and kind of think about it
holiday whether the topic that's my
samsung HTC and the other companies
change because of the Nexus it works
perfectly so it's something that they
added change that causes this problem
yeah they have their own camera
implementations that then you stop
camera implementation understand your
pain like if they're not you know
returning like following the same
patterns and it feels like it's saying
that should probably cover by CVS test
if there isn't one already then you know
you're free to the right one and submit
one is for ccs yes the compatibility
test suite so it's a serious
every single Android device that wants
to run the google mobile services has to
has passed okay have you also looked
with her there any specific SDKs that
Santa more those OEMs release as part of
the downloads for the end SDK well I
looked you know I compared on both
versions on ginger but an ice cream and
they both do the same thing because I've
got the galaxy s2 with Gingerbread and
I've got the galaxy s3 with ice cream
and they know what I mean is that some
of ian's providers part of the or
Android SDK download some special
libraries have you checked in there you
know when you running the SDK manager
okay register I don't think there's
anything special for samsung just I mean
covering all the angles I know this
motorola but i don't think there is any
Samsung I'll check but I don't think so
my view was that there may be a device
sample pricing life okay in the meantime
we have another question worry from like
no power usually few pager is it
possible to skip some views based on
some condition and for example may
normal view flow on the view pager is a
to b to c to d it's not as an option
first we go from A to D yeah the answer
is yes in your data element just as
getting in a vent instantiating a little
handler function right yeah you have it
in the adapter and just miss the pages
out when I asked for them boy you can do
view pager dot set current item and then
there's an option on set current item to
go to the item number and also whether
you want to smooth scroll to it whether
you just want to flip to it so you can
use it there's a sample code out there
that it's leave it's part of the the
support d for demo sample that mashes up
a tab host to
gather with the fragment pager or a view
pager and and it does like rich just
said because of course when you hit the
different tabs there's no sequential
right it's just whichever one you pick
and so it has to push the right one into
both places so go ahead and download the
support v4 devil sample and look at that
one pic is called fragment tab major or
something like that and there's also i
took that same demo when I stuck it into
a code that google com project called I
think I called a Sherlock demo which
takes that exact same piece of code and
sticks it up in the Sherlock action bar
so that's a couple places you might look
at how to get essentially random access
into your fragments in your good idea
Sparkie okay yeah there's a few of those
examples i'm at the task would be
definitely a place to look for that
Bubba there was one other from yo Han I
haven't read this yet so who knows where
we're going to go here is it possible to
hook into the phone call back api's like
when sending gsm codes when i try to
send a request to apply the stator to my
own phone number broadcast in life i
only get a dialog pop up with the answer
but i need the answer is text t1 a
dialer a star hash number maybe to get
sense of the phone and then receive um
well the way i would consider doing is
nothing in the source code to the phone
app see what the phone app does then you
know ended up it yeah i think of some of
that stuff is handled by privileged
privileged libraries in this may really
are the Terran those get Luke Donald
yeah I think you can you can die all
those things but you may not be able to
read the responses okay I'll sign up
there could be
you're only people usually send those
codes by by sending an attempt to the
dialer what city reply to it not that I
can post this anywhere cuz I'm not
looking to the Dorian money yeah look in
phone kit and see how they manage it in
there to start hash numbers there'll be
a bit of special sauce in there because
there's some things which don't actually
make phone calls like start hash 06 ash
and start a Schnauzer a zorro action so
somewhere around there they'll be the
special codes that dealing with but yeah
you're right it might have to be signed
by the system set either yeah it may
well be in the secure package for me
yeah and if it is then you just can't do
it it's quite I can you can't do it
unless you somehow nice okay well at
least should be able to find the answer
in front get in the Android source code
so i did look at my apt manager well um
while you guys were mine sdk manager
while you guys were discussing this
other question and there is at least one
samsung plugin for the sdk because
there's none for the galaxy tab that's
game but i didn't see any for any other
devices this is just a stereo is it an
entire room that system image what if
that's one said they're all blond doll
is typing about the SMS MMS I've seen
that the database technician change from
different phones today debates
definition is yeah it's black box yay so
see if we really met database directly
necessarily yeah there isn't a potion
content provided for those things there
are people who do access them for doing
SMS backup and other things but it is
completely down to the handset
manufacturer if they want to change the
SMS app and put customers less up on
that and they can do that
okay Ivy third come the SMS applications
work what do you mean you can register
for you can read in my test message you
can get that the permission and then
when SMS is come in and just process
them and put it inside your app you
store them however you want to store
them they shouldn't necessarily be
reading and writing directly from the
you noticed Nikki thoughts store is yet
by the implementation yeah yeah baby
people get kind of twitchy about
what you do with SMS is the the the
ability to read and write you know to do
to send and receive the messages it's
pretty carefully controlled because it
has the ability to a cost the user money
and be screw with the telephone network
so yes true no one thought leaders don't
get impressive feedback using the
default SMS application and that's fair
enough and if they do i'll use the
default messaging database but the
database isn't too published api so we
may change the format of it with every
release yeah it's not so nothing is
genesis in the story to the calendar and
you have content provider the longest
time and it wasn't a published public
API like the calendar and many apps you
know worked it out and you know operates
over the calendar and works fine but you
know as I've said we were that
implementation could change at any time
and break the application it wasn't
until ice cream sandwich when there's a
published public content provider that
it's now there's a contractor you can
now operator get the contract and assume
it's going to work ah moving on one more
time yeah that's me so pool blunder and
the chat asks what would you recommend
to use an XML parser or a default Hamlet
the sats passing I which is faster all
uses less memory I've not really used a
sax parser too much but i believe the
pool passes generally the way to go
that's my pants definitely go for the
pool party i usually use a sax father
but i've switched to the xml full patch
as well it's more efficient it's easier
to use you skip all the tags that you're
not looking for
yeah I would go for the xml cool buzzer
Betty entities exhale now there's an
article on the Android developer blog
which i'll post a link to about this ok
it is I'll put it on I'm stickin in the
shut up spark is already on it he's put
a sample in a Hell the support library
frame with Pat pager that was for can
you put that in the Dorian 12 Sparky on
that question because I not going to the
door emo did that get that going to
moderator and and see that he only came
on the mother is an honest of chick Tori
for moderator my god because they know
on what doesn't oh you got it it to the
what would you recommend XML or pious
intersex person yeah I I decided on XML
parser as well I member reading and
videos though about this on IBM
developerworks which is really
interesting yes yes xml parser seems to
be more Android it's used internally
like I think even like even the intent
system uses xml parser to marshal and on
Marshall the extras in the intense yeah
I'm done menus like when you inflate a
menu for example and usable bottom line
so whoo love it subscribe here in and
that's the action on part of her
actually I compact me to the pool party
popper that's not a heads on screen okay
oh my oh yes you can it is funny it
isn't
so till I've not managed to get my hands
on the galaxy s3 what are your first
impressions okay tars on it since that
is just not speaking hey Kyle mm-hmm if
you come back can you tell us is that
not yeah can you tell us you are
thoughts on samsung galaxy s3 we still
don't have one here well no that's it I
got a message from him the other day I
think the first thing that you said
about it was it's big it's big
definitive review of a galaxy s3 itchin
so here's my galaxy s3 unfortunately um
come on people ask some questions we've
got 30 minutes to go and okay well I've
got a question um it was one you briefly
alluded to earlier on on the moderator
I've just put a link to mr. screenshot
of what the problem is its when the
keyboard pops up it's distorting the
background and that's on my relative
layout yeah I don't want if you and if
you look at the image it's really
obvious what the problem is and I'm I'd
rather it could it cropped the
background rather than it resized it
like that so using a just resize rather
than just time there by this and this
one isn't just resized yeah because the
space where that kind of checkered
layout is that's just a listview
normally so it makes sense using just
resize and are you using a background
image on you are using an image that's
that's a background of the relative
layout that's holding all of that sorry
that's holding the bit in the middle yes
as a background to retire lately
trickier image view is the background
layer and then set the scale top excuse
me set the style to scale type
so what the scale types change from so
what I want to be like a like matrix I
suppose I'm just bringing up now senator
crop it depends yeah how whether you
want to create an image that's big
enough to fit or whether you're scaling
the image up as it is and it shouldn't
be that image is is bigger than the
normal kind of 800 x 480 screen but I
couldn't fit a tablet so it needs to be
stretched if it's on a tablet to make
sure it fills all the corners I suppose
I could provide a bigger image but you
only want to be taller and they piloted
a target would be a really good one year
that's an idea I don't know you know I
haven't heard of being able to both
stretch and center or crop I kind of
thought you have to choose I think I got
it sliding really then you have a much
smaller image and just having you know
an XML grub or wrapping it saying the
tile mode so if I'm using it if I'm
tiling like it like that at that point
are we having to use like a surface of
you behind actually draw it out not good
what a timer you can just do a shake
durable oh yeah yeah just have an XML
you don't know durable just a bit that
throw by B and then you can set the tile
mode to a Pete I think in a bit in a
bubble and then you can just set that as
your background global resource okay is
it like like I'll find you for you as a
small amount of XML you can wrap around
the image yeah typical here I'm just
going to copy in basically that our copy
of both community stack overflow yeah
and then you just stick that little bit
of XML inside your layout instead of be
and that has the benefit that you be
able to have a much smaller yeah just
have a for viral or durable like numbers
of Britain's up yeah i would also minute
for it we don't have to have multiple
versions for tablets and everything that
it's okay you scare that with the whole
thing it'll be all mine you might even
be reading it your background image yeah
just just yes sir does your back onto
your android backgrounds refers to is
that this that totals in that
thank you can I other people who aren't
inside the chat will post that link on
to the common thread for the videos for
the Hangout welcome having a so I can
Steve going out with the tiling and
still and still have a neat grading that
goes across the screen what it's boxing
you showed people at the drop box again
maybe do that as well that little thing
at the bottom can be a separate image
layered on top in fact it already is if
you're talking about kind of this the
red with the stitching at the top where
what gradient were you talking about
yeah yeah because it looks like it's
sort of darker on the left a bottle on
the way oh yes actually you know you're
right it is well you did over later all
right so if you have a layer which is a
gradient and a layer behind it which is
the bit map tiles you could probably do
it that way yeah that would work we are
then the gradient is just a 1 pixel
strip which goes across the top yeah
flan pixel deep and then the Wickery
bridge is very doable in bed just might
be careful with how many transparent
layers that you have I understand that
some devices are quite limited with how
many simultaneous stacks transparent
layers they can deal with in the
hardware so you need to want to have
more than like two or three transparent
textures straight I'm identical a deja
terrible i'm hoping it on it composes it
into one image and doesn't like photons
are transplanted so we'll see yeah we
can maybe use an xml layer list with the
bitmap drawable and then the gradient on
top but my ll it's not that rubble yeah
that might work okay I'll try that a
couple of XML files then you end up with
that I like that which scales to
experience yeah I much prefer to define
tasing XML but there's yeah they're much
more likely to scale nicely with things
like tablets and so on then if I'm
trying to you know pick the maximum size
a drawable to include in the APK yeah
makes sense
I see the natural amongst more
information about large emulators he
doesn't want to just go with my snarky
suggestive downloaded google TV is
decayed so he rejected you answer yes
you can reject it he simply said he
wanted more fedex valasek honey singh
google TV about Windows Windows do
people use Windows you will you'll be
surprised it's quite popular windows I
know it's great strange that is a GV SDK
is based on Katie arises as the next
next time yeah I'm google TV cannot work
on Windows the SDK yeah he might have to
run in at the end well I'm just trying
to do what he said you know to run this
configuration and see what happens I if
my computer crashes or anything else
crashes oh well you asked about the s4
in the meantime it's quite a nice device
you know it des voice is quite nice also
it actually really recognizes my voice
very the disadvantage is it doesn't sync
with google for calendar for some reason
it doesn't download all of my new stuff
that i had ha whatever they replace the
calendar implantation with the rain yeah
i guess so because they like when I when
I first of all created my user it
actually worked you know it synced all
of my information but now that I add new
events it doesn't sink ha he connects
the accounts and settings in check that
all the sinking items Earth seeking yes
ok cool ah sounds like about I was
workable
so in the chat comments Paul London
asked question if you are not creating
an app widget is there any reason to use
a service for my apps background tasks
could I just use a singleton reference
from the application so to which I say
yes there's lots of the reasons the main
being is kind of how Android is set up
so there's lots of framework around the
service class which you can make use of
so things like and the ability to
restart a service if it gets killed off
by the by the system should you need it
and with us and services to the ability
to have a binder interface other apps
than interfacing new and you have your
service learning have a different
priority to the loan application so if
the application gets killed the service
still runs like the music player for
example to keep own music in the service
this is so I've experienced it's
basically the way Android has been built
for doing tasks which don't require a UI
whereas a singleton you might have to
write a lot of this functionality
yourself and so I would say use the
framework where where you can because
it's being written to help you out I
also like to always point out that the
syntax for using on an intentservice i
think is simpler than creating an async
task look electric um if you're talking
about using a singleton just for holding
application scope data I would say
you're probably better off using shared
preferences interested I don't want to
move memory whole time and in your chat
Michael that asks single things are
discouraged on Android well I definitely
I think they have their time in a place
but I just think when you're talking
about doing background services that the
service is being created especially for
this kind of this kind of thing so and
it helps you out in a lot of ways so I
wouldn't discard them just because you
use having using the floor embrace them
it was so cool another story yeah we can
take more resources but singleton to
fight Easter what does anyone now Mabel
is saying here she regrets area
preferences
slower well that depends on how you
store them I mean especially in the
singleton like I've seen discussion
where people said you should implement a
map in your single tenant use you know
key value appears in this map and your
in your application level singleton and
my thought their reading that was well
how do you think sure I'd reference this
work I mean you know it isn't it exactly
the same yeah I thought shared
preferences were written in XML to the
flash memory i think is michelle sighs
Michael head low saying as well okay
enjoy getting back to services I mean
it's also much more robust to implement
according to the best practices for
Android because sooner or later you
might want to change something and then
you find yourself having to redevelop
whole bunch of code because you didn't
use the service in the first place I'm
going back to is it my poor Michelle
that when I can you name a problem
instantiating the emulator so I think
you will not already being much help
here like I think the best place to
actually follow this thing is if you go
to tools that Android upon the tools
team be greatly you know the Eclipse
plug-in and work on the emulator and so
on might be better place to ask this
question so if you post in their youth
groups are very responsive in that they
might be able to help keep up this
question ways I don't thinking but the
right people here the only other thing I
can think is maybe try to see if you can
launch it was a whole bunch more with a
whole bunch more Emery in your post
process if you can just you know see you
whichever places you can go to give it
more memory try to get at one memory I
just give it a go and it worked fine
it's on a configuration with a call I
seven and six a gigabyte of the Sun woo
okay hey I think we're about out of time
we are well I want to thank everybody
for joining in and giving us once again
a lively discussion about the latest and
greatest topics in and her involvement
for this week and we will see you all
again at this time next week so everyone
cheers yaks everyone sweet thanks 5
discussion